Keterjeratan kuantum membolehkan zarah-zarah dikaitkan tanpa mengira jarak antara diorang. Ini sangat menentang
akal sampai Einstein sendiri tak percaya ia betul. Dalam episod Qiskit in the classroom harini kita akan bincang macam mana teorem Bell
membuktikan Einstein
silap. Selamat datang ke Qiskit in the classroom. Dalam siri ni kita guna Qiskit untuk terokai konsep asas yang selalu
dicakup dalam kursus berkaitan Quantum Computing. Setiap video juga ada modul interaktif
yang dilink dalam deskripsi bawah, so pastikan korang tengok. Dalam video quantum coins kita bincang macam mana mengukur
superposisi kuantum adalah proses yang sememangnya berupaya seperti melambung duit syiling — tapi macam mana kita tahu
ni betul? Boleh jadi zarah kuantum secara rahsia menyembunyikan keputusan ukuran yang telah ditetapkan tapi kita entah macam mana
gagal rakam maklumat ni dalam teori kita? Pada zaman awal mekanik kuantum soalan ni adalah subjek
debat sengit dengan dua puak utama. Dalam satu kem ada Einstein yang percaya mekanik kuantum adalah tidak lengkap —
iaitu ia terlepas beberapa pembolehubah yang perlu untuk huraikan sistem sepenuhnya. Einstein fikir bahawa
pembolehubah tersembunyi ni kalau dijumpai akan selesaikan beberapa aspek mekanik kuantum yang nampak paradoks dan berupaya.
Dalam kem yang satu lagi ada Max Born. Born berhujah
bahawa huraian berupaya yang diberi oleh mekanik kuantum adalah segalanya yang ditentukan oleh alam semula jadi — dengan kata lain ia
bukan sekadar kita tak tahu keadaan zarah sebelum mengukurnya — zarah tu memang tak ada keadaan yang tertentu
sebelum ia diukur. Selama berdekad-dekad ramai yang fikir pertikaian ni adalah soalan falsafah yang mungkin tidak pernah
dapat diselesaikan. Lagipun untuk tahu apa-apa pasal sesebuah sistem kita kena ukurnya — macam mana kita mungkin tahu apa-apa
tentang sifat keadaan sebelum ia diukur? Kemudian pada tahun 1964 ahli fizik
John Bell jumpa jalan keluarnya. Dalam makalahnya, Bell periksa korelasi statistik antara ukuran sepasang
zarah yang terjerat. Kalau sebelum pengukuran keadaan zarah-zarah tu ditentukan oleh beberapa pembolehubah tersembunyi yang tidak diketahui,
maka Bell jumpa bahawa korelasi diorang ada had atas. Sebaliknya bila dia kira
korelasi yang diramalkan oleh mekanik kuantum dia jumpa bahawa ia melanggar had ini. So dia dah jumpa cara untuk sekali gus
bezakan antara pandangan Einstein dan Born. Yang tinggal cuma nak uji korelasi-korelasi ni secara eksperimen
dengan zarah sebenar untuk tengok sama ada ia ikut statistik pembolehubah tersembunyi atau ia
melanggar peraturan tu. Ujian-ujian ini telah dijalankan dengan ketepatan dan kecanggihan yang semakin meningkat
sepanjang tahun dan ia antara eksperimen paling penting dalam fizik moden. Ia sangat revolusioner sampai
ia membolehkan tiga ahli fizik meraih Hadiah Nobel pada tahun 2022. Tapi sekarang sesiapa pun boleh jalankan
ujian Bell. Yang kita perlukan hanyalah sedikit pengetahuan tentang Qiskit dan akses kepada komputer kuantum IBM. Dalam video ni aku akan
bawa korang melalui logik ketaksamaan Bell, kemudian aku akan tunjuk macam mana kita boleh uji ramalan Bell pada komputer kuantum IBM.
Ketaksamaan Bell melibatkan beberapa pengukuran berbeza dan lapisan logik dan ia boleh jadi
agak sukar untuk diikuti, tapi kita akan lalui langkah demi langkah dan pada akhirnya ia akan berbaloi. Kita nak tunjukkan
bahawa keterjeratan adalah nyata dan Einstein salah — bukan ramai orang yang boleh kata diorang dah buat benda tu. So ni dia
yang Bell cadangkan. Katakanlah korang ada cara untuk hasilkan banyak salinan sepasang zarah yang terjerat. Secara fizikal
pasangan-pasangan ni boleh dihasilkan melalui proses pereputan di mana satu zarah reput menjadi dua. Kalau korang tengok video tentang
eksperimen Stern-Gerlach korang tahu bahawa zarah boleh ada momentum sudut intrinsik yang dipanggil
spin. Katakanlah satu zarah spin sifar reput menjadi dua zarah spin 1/2.
Kemudian setiap zarah spin 1/2 boleh diukur ada sama ada spin tambah setengah atau tolak
setengah, yang juga dipanggil spin up atau spin down. Tapi sebab ia reput dari zarah spin sifar, kedua-duanya mesti bergabung untuk
ada jumlah spin sifar juga. So kalau satu diukur naik, yang satu lagi mestilah
turun dan begitu sebaliknya. Zarah-zarah ini membentuk pasangan yang terjerat yang nampak macam ni.
So kalau satu diukur naik yang satu lagi turun dan begitu sebaliknya. Katakanlah zarah satu terbang ke kiri iaitu
arah minus X di mana penyelidik yang kita panggil Lucas mengukur spin
dia. Kemudian zarah dua pula terbang ke kanan
di mana penyelidik lain Rihanna boleh ukur spin tu. Lucas dan Rihanna boleh secara bebas
putar alat ukuran masing-masing untuk memilih nak ukur spin zarah masing-masing sepanjang mana-mana arah
yang berserenjang dengan arah gerakan zarah. Kalau kita hantar banyak salinan keadaan yang terjerat kepada Lucas
dan Rihanna, diorang boleh kumpul statistik pengukuran. Kalau diorang sentiasa ukur sepanjang paksi yang sama, statistik ni tak akan
terlalu menarik — setiap kali seorang ukur spin up yang seorang lagi ukur spin down, setiap kali seorang ukur spin
ke depan yang seorang lagi ukur spin ke belakang dan seterusnya. Tapi kalau dua penyelidik tu ukur sepanjang paksi berbeza kita mungkin jumpa
sesuatu yang lebih menarik. Jom bagi Lucas dan Rihanna tiga paksi untuk diukur.
Kita panggil paksi-paksi ni a, b, dan c dan ia masing-masing dipisahkan oleh
120°. Soalan yang kita akan tanya dengan eksperimen ni ialah: kalau Lucas dan Rihanna bebas nak ukur sepanjang mana-mana tiga
paksi, berapa kerap kedua-dua akan dapat tanda yang sama? Jelas kalau Lucas dan Rihanna kebetulan ukur sepanjang paksi yang sama
katakanlah paksi a, diorang tak boleh dapat tanda yang sama sebab zarah-zarah mesti bergabung ada spin sifar. Tapi bila diorang pilih
paksi berbeza, macam mana ukuran diorang akan dikaitkan kalau ada pun? Mengikut Einstein, huraian mekanik kuantum
tentang keadaan zarah adalah tidak lengkap. Dia fikir mesti ada pembolehubah tersembunyi yang
tentukan hasil semua kemungkinan ukuran spin — sebab tanpa itu zarah yang terjerat terpaksa
entah macam mana sampaikan hasil ukuran diorang antara satu sama lain dengan segera. Kalau satu diukur
naik di sini, yang satu lagi mesti segera tahu nak turun di sana.
Pembolehubah tersembunyi ni boleh jadi mana-mana set arahan yang rumit untuk hasil eksperimen, tapi intinya ialah
keadaan spin setiap zarah secara berasingan adalah ditentukan, so tiada komunikasi diperlukan.
WEBVTT
Secara eksperimen itu bermakna ukuran yang dibuat oleh Lucas tidak akan memberi kesan kepada zarah Rihanna dan begitu sebaliknya.
Ini boleh meletakkan had pada tahap korelasi yang mungkin antara dua ukuran tu. Mengikut Born pula, keadaan
psi adalah segalanya yang boleh dikatakan tentang pasangan zarah sebelum pengukuran, so ukuran satu zarah
memberi kesan kepada hasil ukuran yang satu lagi. Ini mungkin ada implikasi berbeza untuk korelasi antara ukuran. Jom tengok macam mana setiap
teori mempengaruhi korelasi ni. Dalam rawatan pembolehubah tersembunyi, ada set arahan rahsia sebelum
pengukuran yang dah tentukan apa yang Lucas akan ukur sepanjang setiap tiga paksi. Contohnya arahan-arahan
tu boleh jadi positif kalau Lucas ukur sepanjang paksi a,
positif kalau dia ukur sepanjang b, dan negatif kalau dia ukur sepanjang c. Kita boleh
tulisnya sebagai tambah a tambah b dan tolak c. Kemudian zarah Rihanna
perlu ada pembolehubah tolak a tolak b dan tambah c untuk pastikan jumlah
spin sepanjang mana-mana satu arah adalah sifar.
Ada lapan set arahan yang mungkin yang memenuhi kekangan spin sifar ni, so setiap kali sepasang zarah baru
dihantar kepada Lucas dan Rihanna ia boleh mengandungi mana-mana satu daripada lapan set arahan tu. So sekarang kita nak
cari tahu — dengan anggapan zarah-zarah tu mengandungi salah satu set arahan rahsia yang diberikan dalam jadual tu dan
dengan anggapan Lucas dan Rihanna masing-masing bebas pilih paksi mana daripada tiga paksi tu nak diukur — apakah
kebarangkalian bahawa kedua-dua akan ukur tanda yang sama? Kalau arahan-arahan itu seperti yang diberikan dalam baris 1 atau
8, jelas kebarangkalian ni adalah sifar sebab dua zarah tu akan ada tanda yang berlawanan tanpa mengira paksi
ukuran diorang. Tapi macam mana kalau arahan dalam baris dua? Diorang akan ukur tanda yang sama kalau
Rihanna ukur sepanjang c dan Lucas ukur sepanjang sama ada a atau b, atau kalau Lucas
ukur sepanjang c dan Rihanna ukur sepanjang sama ada A atau B. So itu empat daripada sembilan
kombinasi ukuran yang mungkin yang akan bagi Lucas dan Rihanna tanda yang sama. Kalau kita buat ni untuk
setiap set arahan korang akan nampak bahawa baris 3 hingga 7 juga bagi kebarangkalian 4 per 9. Ini bermakna kalau
Einstein betul dan pembolehubah tersembunyi macam ni menentukan hasil ukuran, tak ada cara Lucas
dan Rihanna boleh ukur tanda yang sama dengan kebarangkalian lebih besar daripada 4 per 9. Ini ialah ketaksamaan Bell: P lebih kecil atau
sama dengan 4 per 9. Dan seperti yang kita akan tunjukkan, zarah yang terjerat melanggar ni. So untuk
tengok apa yang mekanik kuantum ramalkan, katakanlah Lucas ukur sepanjang a. Dua benda boleh berlaku — sama ada dia ukur spin up so
Rihanna akan ukur spin down sepanjang a, atau dia ukur spin down dan Rihanna akan ukur spin up sepanjang a. Tapi kita
nak kebarangkalian bahawa Rihanna ukur tanda yang sama dengan Lucas sepanjang mana-mana paksi yang dia pilih — bukan setakat a. Kalau
dia ukur sepanjang sama ada B atau C ia jadi sedikit rumit. Rupanya
kalau korang tahu apa yang Rihanna akan ukur dengan kepastian 100% sepanjang satu arah, korang boleh kira kebarangkalian
bahawa dia akan ukur ke atas atau ke bawah sepanjang mana-mana paksi lain dengan sedikit geometri.
Kalau keadaan korang sentiasa ukur spin up sepanjang satu paksi, kebarangkalian ukur spin up sepanjang paksi berbeza
akan sama dengan kuasa dua kosinus separuh sudut antara dua paksi tu. Itu agak rumit tapi
aku akan tunjukkan apa yang aku maksudkan. Kalau Lucas ukur spin up sepanjang a kita tahu dengan kepastian 100% bahawa Rihanna akan ukur
spin down kalau dia ukur a. So kita boleh wakilkan itu dengan vektor
macam ni. Dalam kes ni sudut antara vektor ni dengan dua paksi ukuran lain B dan C adalah
kedua-duanya 60°. So separuh daripada itu ialah 30° dan kosinus
30 ditunjukkan di sini. Kosinus kuasa dua
30° sama dengan 3 per 4. Sekarang macam mana kalau Lucas ukur spin down
sepanjang a? Kita tahu Rihanna akan ukur spin up sepanjang a. So kita boleh lukis vektor lain di sini. Sekarang
vektor ini yang mewakili pengetahuan ni adalah 120° dari setiap dua paksi lain B
dan C. So kita boleh buat trik geometri yang sama tapi kali ni kita akan dapat kosinus
60°. So kosinus kuasa dua
60° sama dengan 1 per 4. Sebab Lucas sama-sama mungkin untuk
ukur spin up dan spin down sepanjang a, kita kena puratakan dua kebarangkalian Rihanna ni. Kita dapat kebarangkalian akhir
bahawa Rihanna akan ukur tanda yang sama dengan Lucas sebesar 1 per 2. So P
sama dengan setengah. Setengah lebih besar daripada 4 per 9 so ketaksamaan Bell dilanggar.
Itu bermakna selagi peraturan mekanik kuantum berlaku, pembolehubah tersembunyi adalah mustahil. Sekarang kita boleh guna Qiskit dan
komputer kuantum IBM untuk uji ketaksamaan Bell dengan ukuran kuantum sebenar. Kita boleh petakan keadaan spin up dan
spin down zarah Lucas dan Rihanna kepada keadaan sifar dan satu qubit dalam komputer kuantum. Kita akan
ambil dua qubit, satu untuk mewakili zarah Lucas dan satu untuk zarah Rihanna, dan jeratan diorang dengan circuit Quantum ni.
So dua qubit diwakili oleh dua wayar q0 dan q1 dan kombinasi
gate X, Hadamard dan c not ini akan hasilkan keadaan yang terjerat sama yang ada antara zarah Lucas dan Rihanna. Sekarang kita
kena ukur setiap qubit. Kita akan tetapkan ukuran Lucas sepanjang a, yang kita kata ialah paksi Z. Kemudian ukuran Rihanna boleh
sepanjang a, b atau c so kita perlukan tiga circuit berasingan untuk setiap tiga kes tu. Tapi dalam
video ni kita akan buat satu je. Korang boleh pergi ke modul yang dilink dalam deskripsi untuk versi penuh. Kalau Rihanna ukur sepanjang
B, circuit kita nampak macam ni di mana ry ialah putaran 120 darjah untuk tukar
paksi ukuran Rihanna. Kita boleh guna Qiskit primitive sampler untuk jalankan eksperimen ni banyak kali dan kumpul
statistik dari ukuran yang terhasil. Dua lajur 0 0 dan 1 1 mewakili masa bila Lucas dan
Rihanna ukur tanda yang sama — itulah yang kita cari. So kebarangkalian mengukur kedua-dua zarah ada
tanda yang sama hampir setengah. Ini melanggar ketaksamaan Bell. Ini bermakna
WEBVTT
bahawa dua zarah tu memang terjerat — setiap satu entah macam mana nampaknya segera tahu keputusan ukuran
yang satu lagi. Masih ada sedikit pertikaian tentang macam mana tepat nak tafsirkan
keterjeratan ni dan apa yang berlaku bila korang ukur keadaan yang terjerat, tapi soalan-soalan ini lebih bersifat falsafah.
Teorinya memang tak boleh dinafikan pada ketika ni — keterjeratan memang nyata dan kita tahu ni berkat Bell, ketaksamaan
dia, dan ramai ahli fizik yang telah menjalankan eksperimen untuk mengujinya. Kalau korang nak dikira antara ahli-ahli fizik tu
dan jalankan ujian Bell sendiri dengan komputer kuantum, pastikan pergi ke modul ketaksamaan Bell
yang dilink dalam deskripsi. Terima kasih kerana menonton, jumpa korang next time.